hi my name is
finding charge of regional office kpmg
and I have a question here from Brian
McCann is st sniffs I yo participation
economic developers of how should you
people getting home and I'll say that to
my face White Mountains region
for sure this young power force will be
very important for the development of
the region what's really important that
the young people have to every marine
right now he said invest in yourself
then get ready for the challenges that
will be coming so you need to know at
least two or three languages English
sewer Spanish other language but you
know guest gets really prepared in
advancing yourself in terms of Education
that's key so if you are well prepared
you'll be a benefit from the challenges
from your purchasing speaker head for
sure